Rajneesh and his friend Hiro have a dish  to go with the chutney it's a sort of  chicken hotpot first the chicken is  mixed with a paste made from chili  garlic and ginger then it's put into the  basket made from woven leaves from the  Sal tree  it's a little bit water that helps  esteem the chicken sample 14  so now we are stitching unbelievable  like she's covering the chicken with  pastry but it's not it's a leaf so that  goes inside another fire little too far  you can't turn down the heat or turn up  the heat  are you sure that's gonna be cooked  ah oven gloves  tell me duping oh I delicious okay yeah  no really good thank you so much  well done hero staying with the  derivative has been a real eye-opener  incredible  they have nothing yet they've developed  these ingenious techniques on how to  cook delicious food quite touching  amazing stuff